[Musique]
super je retourne à château pour
détruire
le je
[Musique]
viens
maisous
à plus tard mon brave partenaire de labo
ça
marche ban
banane ok ok on y va au
bateau maison maison maison
[Musique]
maison j'en reviens pas que le flitz
medifer a pu créer tout ça c'est
magnifique ce serait pas des gant boins
ça des
flamangues mais c'est quoi ça là-bas une
tomate en
2014 non
non j'aime ça moi aussi c'est à moi non
non à moi donne-moi ça non non pourquoi
je discute avec un cornichon si vous
avez le goût de l'aventure
accrochez-vous c'est pas le moment
deter et si SAU le monde vous fait
saliver tu as gagné il s'est confituré
dessus alors préparez-vous à déguster
[Musique]
courz ce sera pas d' t l'île des miam
nimo Steve
Steve